>> Trace: NEW YORK’S OFFICIAL
COUNT OF MORE THAN 8,000 NURSING
HOME DEATHS COULD BE UP TO 50%
HIGHER BRINGING THE POTENTIAL
TALLY CLOSER TO 13,000.
MAYBE MORE.
THAT’S ACCORDING TO A BOMB SHELL
REPORT FROM THE NEW YORK
ATTORNEY GENERAL’S OFFICE SAYING
THE STATE UNDERCOUNTED.
THEY ALSO SAID RESIDENTS COULD
HAVE BEEN AT INCREASED RISK IN
FACILITIES.
HERE RIGHT NOW, GEORGE PATAKI.
GOOD OF YOU TO COME ON.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
I FIND THE NUMBERS STRIKING.
50% OF COVID DEATHS
UNDERCOUNTED.
THE STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID
THIS.
AS THE PANDEMIC AND OUR
INVESTIGATION CONTINUES, IT’S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
WHY THE RESIDENTS OF NURSING
HOMES IN NEW YORK UNNECESSARILY
BEING THE KEY WORD SUFFERED AT
SUCH AN ALARMING RATE AND YET
THERE HAVE BEEN LITTLE, IF ANY,
CONSEQUENCES.
YOU HAVE THE GOVERNOR GETTING
AWARDS AND BOOK DEALS.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> THIS IS A NEW LOW.
FOR MONTHS, LEGISLATORS,
EVERYONE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
THE NUMBERS FROM THE GOVERNOR’S
OFFICE AND THEY STONE WALLED.
NOW WE KNOW WHY.
THEY WERE MISREPRESENTING IT
FROM THE BEGINNING.
I KNOW ABOUT LEADING IN A
CRISIS.
YOU HAVE TO DO TWO THINGS.
YOU WANT TO MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS.
OR IF YOU MAKE A DECISION YOU
QUESTION, CHANGE IT.
SECONDLY, COMMUNICATE HONESTLY
WITH THE PEOPLE.
ON BOTH OF THOSE FRONTS, THE
CUOMO ADMINISTRATION FAILED
MISERABLY.
THEY MADE THE WRONG DECISION AND
REFUSED TO CORRECTED IT WHEN IT
WAS POINTED OUT AND NOW IT
APPEARS THEY LIED TO THE PEOPLE
OF NEW YORK ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES, THIS IS
INEXCUSABLE.
>> Trace: YEAH.
WE SHOULD KNOW THAT GOVERNOR
CUOMO AND HIS OFFICE HAVE NOT
RESPONDED TO THIS REPORT.
THE GOVERNOR DID SAY THIS
YESTERDAY ON A DIDN’T NETWORK.
WATCH.
>> INCOMPETENT GOVERNMENT KILLS
PEOPLE.
INCOMPETENT GOVERNMENT KILLS
MORE PEOPLE DIED THAN NEEDED TO
DIE IN COVID.
THAT’S THE TRUTH.
INCOMPETENT GOVERNMENT CAN KILL
PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT A JOKE.
MORE PEOPLE DIED HERE THAN
NEEDED TO.
>> HE’S NOT TALKING ABOUT
HIMSELF BUT HE IS CORRECT.
INCOMPETENT GOVERNMENT CAN KILL
PEOPLE.
>> TRACE, THAT’S ONE OF THE FEW
THINGS THAT HE GOT RIGHT.
HE IS THE ONE THAT DICTATED THAT
NURSING HOMES TAKE COVID
POSITIVE PATIENTS WHILE HE SAID
THEY WEREN’T CAPABLE OF DOING
WITH IT.
I WAS ONE OF THE FIRST TO SAY
THIS IS IDIOTIC AND GOING TO
CLEVELAND PEOPLE.
I WAS ON TWITTER 48 STRAIGHT
DAYS AND STOP THE MADNESS, STOP
KILLING THE MOST VULNERABLE.
THEY WOULDN’T CHANGE THE POLICY.
IT WAS QUIETLY REVERSED WITHOUT
ANY COMMENT.
BUT TODAY, LESS THAN HALF OF THE
NURSING HOME STAFF IN NEW YORK
STATE HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
YOU KNOW, THEY’VE HAD A PRIORITY
ON NURSING HOMES FROM THE
BEGINNING, YET BECAUSE OF THE
INCOMPETENCE, JUST CAME OUT
TODAY THAT LESS THAN HALF HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED IN NURSING
HOMES, THE STAFFS.
THIS HAS BEEN A DISASTER.
IRONIC.
THE PRESS SAYS WHAT A GREAT JOB
BUT WE HAVE ALMOST AS TWICE AS
MANY DEATHS IN FLORIDA AND SEE
HOW COMPETENTLY THE CUOMO
ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID IT.
>> ELISE STEFANIK SAID --
>> Trace: THE QUESTION IS WILL
THERE BE CONSEQUENCES IN YOUR
ESTIMATION FOR THIS KIND OF
GOVERNING?
LAST THOUGHTS.
>> SENATOR STEFANIK IS RIGHT.
THERE HAS TO BE AN INVESTIGATION
AND SUBPOENAS.
HAS TO BE THE STATE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I BELIEVE FEDERAL OFFICIALS
SHOULD LOOK AT THIS AS WELL.
YOU CAN’T TRUST THE CUOMO
ADMINISTRATION TO INVESTIGATE
ITSELF.
THEY DID THAT AT THE BEGINNING.
THEY CONDUCTED THEIR OWN
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION AND
CONCLUDED THE POLICY OF PUTTING
COVID POSITIVE IN NURSING HOME
WASN’T THE PROBLEM.
IT WAS THE STAFF.
IT WAS A COVER UP.
NOW WE KNOW THE NUMBERS HAVE
COVERED UP.
THEY NEED TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
AND I HOPE IT’S QUICKLY AND
AGGRESSIVE.
>> Trace: FORMER GOVERNOR GEORGE